Allora intanto per me emozionante perché
io ho vissuto tanti anni adesso vivo a
Pesaro ma ho vissuto tanti anni a
Bisceglie sono di Molfetta e quindi già
emozionante parlare qui per me e lo
faccio spesso lo faccio spesso la
relatrice Ma questa emozione non la
sento spesso allora quello che di cui io
vi parlerò è il tentativo che cercherò
di fare è di portare tutti i grandi temi
legati all'ecosostenibilità ai
cambiamenti climatici alla guerra farvi
capire come i grandi temi hanno un
impatto diretto sulla nostra vita Io sto
vivo nelle Marche e sapete bene così
appena successo cioè quando vi dicono
perché vi spiego anche quale è questa
giornata di oggi per me è
particolarmente importante perché quando
si parla di temi di ambiente di temi di
ecosostenibilità Parliamoci chiaro
gliene frega molto poco a tanta gente
quindi quello che io ho capito è che non
devo parlare di ecosostenibilità io devo
far comprendere come risolvo i problemi
delle persone a partire da questo quindi
quando vi dico cambiamenti climatici
sappiate che questo e questo è successo
a 30 km da casa mia questo bambino
Purtroppo lo conoscete tutti e questo è
successo perché aumenta la CO2
sapete cos'è le coppe No Cosa sono le
coppie grandi eventi internazionali Da
quanti anni li fanno vengono fatti per
ridurre la CO2 che crea e genera a 30
chilometri da casa mia ma in tutto il
mondo Attualmente il nord sta vivendo un
pesantissimo un momento di
desertificazione di problemi idrici
vedete da tanti anni ne parliamo grandi
raduni di persone Guardate che fa la CO2
capite bene che chi vi dice che gli
alberi salveranno il mondo come Quanti
ne dobbiamo piantare visto che non ci
fermiamo mai
tema guerra di cosa vi parlano di Putin
dell'Europa vi parlano del delle Armi
nessuno vi dice Quanti morti ci sono
ogni giorno
Noi siamo persone noi ci dobbiamo
occupare delle persone
perché quello che stanno pagando gli
ucraini e quelli quello era
l'aggiornamento a settembre Prima ha
sentito che sono diventati il doppio i
bambini morti e mentre loro muoiono i
nostri cari governanti già dall'inizio
quando hanno detto facciamo gli imbarchi
riduzione dell'illuminazione Questo è il
piano del governo
chi sta pagando loro
noi riduzione volontaria dei consumi
industriali questo significa chiudiamo
le aziende
Le nostre aziende la nostra vita i
nostri figli
riduzione di un grado di riscaldamento
significa soprattutto che gli edifici
pubblici le scuole pagheranno questa
roba qui perché voglio vedere come come
regoleranno nelle case private questo
problema ma sicuramente ridurranno le
condizioni di vita delle scuole e dei
ragazzi che già ne hanno passate tante
col covid
più centrali a Carbone sapete che
significa Ilva
più importazione di gas naturale questo
benedetto gas naturale che
improvvisamente da essere un gas di
sanzioni in Europa è diventato
un'energia Green come nucleare e lo
sanno tutti i tecnici che non è vero
prima di trasformare prima che la
commissione europea confermasse che
metano e nucleare sono energie Green Mi
raccomando allora non interessa niente
di energia Green l'energia Green sono
quelle che vengono finanziate i soldi
una commissione di professionisti del
settore aveva detto state per fare una
cretinata l'hanno fatta lo stesso
il gas come e poi passiamo a Come mai il
gas
viene Comprato ad un prezzo
e guardate a che prezzo viene venduto
questo sarebbe successo dopo la guerra
Ma questo è quello che ha causato la
guerra questo lo crea la speculazione
cioè i gruppi dell'energia
internazionali e ne compresa e denie è
composta 33% da governo italiano 70 per
cento da multinazionali americane
costo del gas naturale significa aumento
delle bollette significa la nostra
economia in ginocchio Ma quando dico
economia significa che chiuderanno le
aziende dei nostri padri dei nostri
amici che le famiglie non sapranno più
di cosa mangiare
e naturalmente questa è la beffa più
grande sapete perché sta crescendo in
maniera così smisurata anche il prezzo
del gas Perché siccome il gas siccome
tutta la normativa europea è stata
costruita per ridurre l'utilizzo di
queste sostanze che aumentano la CO2
adesso che con la guerra stanno
comprando tutti i gas siccome ci sono
dei tetti massimi per la produzione
della CO2 loro ci aumentano il prezzo
del gas Perché devono pagare le [ __ ] si
pagano per l'aumento della produzione
della CO2 quindi noi stiamo pagando la
speculazione che c'è e siamo Anche
pagando perché Quelle aziende per
arricchirsi stanno aumentando la
produzione di CO2 Quindi devono pagare
delle multe noi paghiamo due volte e
paghiamo sempre noi
chiaramente questo sta già provocando
tutto questo
sta già provocando e scusatemi
sta già provocando che le persone nelle
città soprattutto nelle grandi città ma
sta succedendo anche nei piccoli centri
si stanno impoverendo e le figlie alla
Caritas stanno aumentando perché questo
è dai cambiamenti climatici a Cosa
significa utilizzare le fossili stanno
distruggendo la vita delle persone
covid
la conosciamo tutti questa scena questa
questa immagine Bergamo
nessuno vi dice però
che le città dove ci sono stati più
morti sono le città più inquinate
d'Italia
e nessuno vi dice
Ateneo di Bologna studio l'inquinamento
ambientale ha un ruolo rilevante nei
decessi di tumore in Italia noi ci siamo
preoccupati del covid ma ci sono 85.000
persone all'anno che muoiono di tumore
per l'inquinamento non ve lo dice mai
nessuno lo sanno le famiglie Però
naturalmente tumore significa anche
enormi costi dal punto di vista della
spesa Sanitaria di cui nessuno parla
lo smog Killer nella mappa della ricerca
delle Enea 85.000 morti l'anno notate le
stesse zone del covid sapete perché il
covitz si trasferisce di più nelle città
inquinate il particolato nell'aria
inquinamento particolare
e poi qual è una delle sostanze qualcosa
stanno comprando dopo la guerra
tantissimo il gas
Qual è il combustibile che genera più
CO2 il gas
e poi c'è l'altro enorme problema che
stiamo vivendo i giovani
i giovani naturalmente tornando alla
scala italiana stanno abbandonando
l'Italia noi ci preoccupiamo di quanti
ne arrivano nessuno si preoccupa di
quanti se ne vanno via e sono i nostri
ragazzi sono i ragazzi che abbandonano
l'Italia e per cui l'Italia fa
un'enormità di investimenti
e soprattutto
stasera il latmotive le ragazze le
persone più esposte in questo contesto
sono le ragazze per tutti i problemi che
abbiamo detto prima ma per esempio
perché c'è un gender Gap per esempio dal
punto di vista delle paghe che quando si
tratta di operai del 18%, quando si
tratta di aumentare le professioni
livello è diventa fino al 33% a parità
di capacità
quindi non solo siamo in una situazione
difficile per tutti Chi ha Maggiore
fragilità e ancora più esposto e
chiaramente le donne sono solo un tipo
di fragilità sia ben chiaro
però
stiamo parlando delle nuove generazioni
e poi naturalmente c'è tutto il problema
dei ragazzi che non ci credono più
immaginate questo Noi ci troviamo quasi
in una tempesta perfetta vediamo vediamo
dal covid che ha impattato
psicologicamente su di noi in maniera
Tremenda è chiaro che i ragazzi hanno
non attrezzati magari psicologicamente
come gli adulti ad affrontare i problemi
O magari anche per altri motivi non
studiano non lavorano ora in questa
situazione direi cosa tutti dobbiamo
fare non si può Però io penso che cosa
ognuno di noi può fare si può dire o
perlomeno da dove possiamo partire e
faccio lo stesso discorso che hanno
fatto molti prima di me mi è piaciuto
questo molti ci hanno detto ci hanno
parlato i termini che mi sono piaciuti
di più
e avere la consapevolezza del limite
avere la consapevolezza di cosa sta
succedendo e avere delle prospettive
davanti dei sogni Perché senza quelli
non si va da nessuna parte
e voi pensate che fino a qui tutti
questi problemi nessuno li ha analizzati
nessuno ha mai pensato a come risolvere
no
c'è un signore
che l'ha detto nel 75 cosa stava per
succedere è un genio
ma in realtà era una semplicemente una
persona intelligentissima che aveva
capacità di analisi sociologica a
livelli enormi e che aveva già capito
che il consumismo il consumismo non è
altro che trasformare un valore in costo
quello che diceva fondamentalmente
Pasolini e che si era passati da una
cultura del valore magari sbagliato
perché sapete bene che lui ce l'aveva
molto con la chiesa però una cultura di
valore ha una cultura per cui le persone
valgono e tutto ciò che vale il denaro e
quello che abbiamo visto prima
parte tutto da quello perché Ricordatevi
che mentre c'è tutto il mondo ridotto in
quelle condizioni ci sono Express extra
profitti enormi da tutt'altra parte
quindi la realtà che io ho descritto è
quella delle persone perché i mega
gruppi
farmacologici dell'energia le banche
hanno avuto degli extra profitti
pazzeschi mentre la gente si Sta
riducendo in quelle condizioni e lui
l'aveva capito E aveva capito come il
Dio Denaro il consumismo avrebbero
cancellato tutti i valori della nostra
società e lasciato solo l'individuo io
chiaramente quello che vi faccio vedere
adesso Pasolini
lui un altro Gigante secondo me che
aveva capito tante cose ma è morto pare
di incidente era Mattei Ma te che cosa
aveva capito Lui è colui che di fatto ha
costruito lei all'epoca chiaramente
ancora non si sapeva non si conoscevano
le devastazioni delle energie fossili
Però lui che cosa voleva fare
dopo la guerra
rendere l'Italia energeticamente
dipendente per rendere indipendente
politicamente ed economicamente perché
quello che stiamo vivendo noi oggi
l'Italia insieme alla Germania e la più
esposta dal punto di vista energetico
perché dipende dal gas che non ha la
palla che vi dicono che ne abbiamo nel
giacimenti basta per un anno
quindi
Quindi quello che succede Qual è che nel
momento in cui noi non puntiamo a quello
a cui credeva Mattei ha un'indipendenza
energetica che nel nostro ambito in
particolare in Italia significa
soprattutto sole e vento
non lo raggiungeremo mai Anche perché
sole e vento sono gli uniche cose che ci
permettono di avere un Indipendenza
energetica che sia soprattutto a zero
produzione di CO2
e poi c'è questo signore questo signore
è una figura
importantissima che nel suo periodo non
sulle filature però questo signore si
chiama Adriano Olivetti e della persona
che ha messo insieme il pensiero
economico o il pensiero di quelli che
fanno il mio mestiere gli urbanisti i
progettisti Lui chiedeva Prima di tutto
un sogno sembra un sogno fino a quando
non si comincia a lavorarci Cosa
significa che noi siamo in un momento in
cui sembra che non possiamo fare più
niente
perché se uno veramente si mette a
pensare cosa posso fare sembra niente
però se non iniziamo Mai come quella
ragazza ha iniziato ad arrabbiarsi
non inizieremo a fare mai niente e
soprattutto Lui parlava di un utopia
possibile Olivetti sapete tutti Chi è
Olivetti parliamo di colui che ha dato
vita alla Olivetti
ha creato posti di lavoro ha creato una
grandissima impresa ma soprattutto
sapete come l'ha creata mettendo al
centro la comunità dei suoi operai lui
da imprenditore si occupava dei suoi
operai ha costruito Ivrea una città
costruita per far star bene le persone
che c'erano dentro e soprattutto medeva
al centro della sua opera non solo le
relazioni sociali valori ed è questo qui
era uno che puntava a fare denaro ma
metteva al centro valori con la come la
bellezza e la qualità dell'abitare il
già Allora si vede Ivrea se ne accorge
parlava di relazione con la natura Ora
noi in realtà non parliamo dall'anno
zero perché l'Europa prima della guerra
aveva fatto un lavorone che era
cominciato calare direttiva 20/2020 e
che darà finita qui
agenda 2030 Greninja ossia tutta
l'economia convertita verso il Green
mettendo al centro i temi di cui abbiamo
parlato tutti fino a questo momento
comunità al centro in questione sociale
transizione ecologica dal fossile
rinnovabile riduzione del 65% al 2030
della CO2 Carbon neutra significa non
produciamo più CO2 e fermiamo quei
Benedetti cambiamenti
istruzione per tutti gender Gap e
signori l'Europa puntava questo
pace
e l'ho scritto nel suo documento più
importante ma questo documento sapete
cos'è era soprattutto questo Noi abbiamo
tutti i fondi europei attualmente
esistenti che erano stati costruiti per
support che sono stati sono ancora lì
coi soldi fondi strutturali europei 2021
27 per realizzare l'agenda 2030 Jack
next generation you creato per il covid
puntava partiva da quei valori tutti i
fondi nazionali attualmente si muovono
su queste tematiche
Ci sono tantissimi fondi privati ci sono
tante banche che hanno già deciso di
finanziare soprattutto finanziamenti
sostenibile e poi ci sono tutte le varie
compagnie Esco ora qui non voglio
entrare nel dettaglio Ma cosa sta
facendo in questo momento l'Europa
niente Si è fermata hanno ricominciato a
comprare gas stanno di nuovo parlando di
petrolio
Il problema è che stavamo per partire
per salvarci la vita e la guerra fermato
tutto
Cosa possiamo fare noi dal basso Io sono
un tecnico è chiaro che vi devo parlare
di intervenire chi può sulle proprie
case e chi non può agire direttamente
sui propri comportamenti riducendo va
detto che molti di noi hanno un uso
dell'energia completamente smodato
rispetto a quelle che sono le reali
esigenze Però possiamo fare un'altra
cosa sapete chi finanziava tutti i
finanziamenti europei a chi vanno
alle città Quindi le persone a cui
possiamo andare per dire muoviamoci ce
li abbiamo molto vicini sono i sindaci
non dobbiamo andare in Europa per far
fare queste cose non dobbiamo andare al
governo per far fare queste cose i
progetti vengono fatti ed erogati a
Scala comunale Quindi le persone che
possiamo muovere ce li abbiamo accanto a
noi
Io vi dico nel mio piccolo cosa sto
facendo Perché io sono nata dicendo e
dicevo a una ragazza prima occupandomi
di questi temi ho avuto questo slancio
Però io mi è piaciuto che prima la
fisica aveva al Centro Leonardo
noi dobbiamo capire che siamo Leonardo
siamo il centro dal nostro punto di
vista dell'universo ma che ci dobbiamo
muovere con la consapevolezza dei nostri
limiti perché il non avere limiti il
consumo senza fine in natura un sistema
che cresce all'infinito Non esiste solo
noi potevamo immaginare di poter
sfruttare tutto all'infinito senza
creare danni E cosa stiamo sto facendo
io in questo momento sto cercando
proprio perché ho capito la mia sfida e
lavorare a livello comunale ho cercato
di trasformare tutti quei grandi
discorsi che l'Europa ha fatto
in un piano regolatore
semplicemente in un piano regolatore
lavoriamo dove siamo noi
e questo piano regolatore chiaramente Io
adesso sto lavorando a Cristiano
Cristiano 14.000 abitanti città del sud
ogni decisione viene presa punta a
generare lavoro Green perché lì c'è il
lavoro attualmente non c'è da altre
parti ci sono studi e studi che
dimostrano che il lavoro che oggi
puògrerare tutto il mondo Green sono
molto più alti di quelli che può
generare Attualmente il fossile
il piano è costruito per attrarre
investitori perché nel mondo c'è una
marea di investitori Io sto lavorando a
Milano con investitori che hanno
investito di tasca loro per realizzare
parti di Milano completamente Green
perché anche un ambito di vendita questo
sburocratizzare questa bella parola no
voi sentite sempre che il grillo
qualsiasi attività in Italia viene
bloccata dalla burocrazia Peccato che a
me non mi ha mai fermato nessuno per un
progetto
Cosa significa che sicuramente si
possono elaborare le leggi migliorare le
leggi burocratizzare ma si può anche
muovere il mondo della progettazione per
cercare di non andarci ad impattare
addosso sono sempre due strade
riqualificazione energetica tutti gli
edifici Naturalmente per co2 Sì ma è
l'unico modo per abbattere le bollette
Io sono pugliese adoro questa regione ma
la forza di questa regione è il fatto
che ha mantenuto
fortemente e ha rispettato il proprio
territorio io sono arrivato in quel
comune la prima cosa che ho fatto e
studiare la struttura ecosistemica dei
trattori delle Masserie e l'ho messa al
centro dello sviluppo per loro era solo
marketing Io l'ho fatto diventare
il centro di tutti il sistema del Piano
perché quando diciamo la parola
ecosostenibilità cos'è
l'ecosostenibilità e creare reti e quali
sono i modi migliori per tracciare dei
Reti esistono già le strade soprattutto
le strade storiche che si formavano sul
sistema agricolo che si formavano sul
sistema della Transumanza che si trovano
dove ci sono i famosi muretti tutelati e
che si trovano dove a Crispiano ci sono
Le Masserie questo perché l'ho fatto
perché noi pensiamo che la sostenibilità
sia qualcosa di molto lontano da noi ma
non sappiamo quanto noi in particolare
al Sud non avendo devastato il
territorio la sostenibilità ce l'abbiamo
davanti agli occhi
e quanto è molto più facile trovare
sostenibilità dicevo le città più
ecosostenibili attualmente esistenti
sono i centri storici perché la gente ci
viveva senza elettricità e con
l'architetto gli alberi vanno benissimo
ma con l'architettura che si abbatte la
CO2 non piantando gli alberi
in questa città tutto è stato fatto Non
solo permettere a Massimo sistema tutti
i valori di questa città è stata
costruita per attrarre i cittadini una
città ecosostenibile costruito in questa
maniera è in grado di attrarre cittadini
non posso entrare Se nel dettaglio Ma
soprattutto abbiamo risolto un
problemino dicono che non si possono
fare i grandi impianti Peccato che noi
già sappiamo dove metterli E chi viene
realizza e io non ho mosso una legge
italiana
questo fatto in piena collaborazione con
tutti gli uffici della Regione Puglia
che passano per essere fra i maggiori
fetenti in Italia
quello che voglio dire
e questo ragazze i ragazzi non questo io
parlo alle ragazze non perché i ragazzi
siano meno importanti Ma perché
attualmente la vera forza nespressa
dell'Italia il 50% della popolazione Noi
abbiamo bisogno delle energie di tutti
ci sono stupidi e intelligenti fai
maschi ci sono stupidi e intelligenti
fra le donne ma adesso le donne non
possono stare a guardare prima
parlaviamo di violenza ed è un tema di
cui io non mi permetto neanche di
parlare ma questa signora Qui è stata
violentata nel Seicento ed è diventata
la più grande pittrice di quel momento
si può essere fragili e si può essere
forti chi vi racconta che siete fragili
non vi conosce proprio
Le donne hanno delle capacità se molto
forti
e l'obiettivo che dobbiamo avere tutti
Io lavoro per voi e spero che voi
capiate quanto importante la vostra
presenza Uomini e Donne ragazzi e
ragazze in questo momento che voi
schiacciate l'acceleratore Perché noi
dobbiamo mettervi a disposizione le
possibilità ma voi vi dovete alzare da
quelle sedie perché nessuno farà il
vostro lavoro al posto vostro
e soprattutto
questo io ce l'ho sulla scrivania ogni
volta che un momento di difficoltà
perché anche quando si cresce momenti di
difficoltà arrivano sempre però è quello
se non si ha voglia di volare se non si
ha voglia di risolvere i problemi cioè
Bam Che dice che la felicità non è
l'assenza di problemi Baumann è un
grandissimo sociologo e filosofo ha
recentemente fatto un'intervista dove ha
detto la felicità non è l'assenza di
problemi la felicità e la capacità di
superarli i problemi Beh abbiamo una
grandissima occasione Grazie
[Applauso]